نشير الى الخبر العاجل الذي يظهر على
شاشتنا الان اذ افادت وافادت وسائل اعلام
الاسرائيليه باصابه اثنين اسرائيليين خلال
عمليه طعن شرقي القدس وقالت القوات
الاسرائيليه انها اطلقت النار على المنفذ
وحيدته وهذه الصور تاتيكم مشاهدينا الكرام
من الموقع الذي يفترض انه وقع فيه الحادث
شرقي القدس والجيش يقول انه يطلق النار او
انه اطلق النار على فلسطينين على فلسطيني
نفذ العمليه
وحيده حمود حمود
[تصفيق]
حمود حمود
حمود اذا مشاهدينا الكرام هذه الصور التي
تاتيكم م من قرب مستوطنه معلي ادومين
شرقيه القدس اذ تقول وسائل اعلام
الاسرائيليه ان
اسرائيليين اثنين اصيبا في عمليه طعم
شرقيه القدس في تلك او في ذلك الموقع وان
الجيش اطلق النار على فلسطيني هناك
وحيده